I've started taking mushrooms like every
other day
like micro dosing them like a gram
between a gram and a half and two grams
how many of those pills are you left
well I saved you a bag unless one of
them was yours and then I finished my
bag and then I took some more of that
Joe Diaz bar last night and so yeah just
you know me and my girlfriend Iman just
hang out and um
and yeah just hang out watch tick tocks
watch TV like we watched drag race we
started watching the show FBI how often
have you been taking them every other
day yeah like whatever I'm just like
thinking about it and she's like I just
want to hang out downstairs and watch a
bunch of things I'm like well in order
to keep myself up I'll just take some
mushrooms and let me ask you a question
outside of how fun they are
noticed any difference with your mental
or your mood your attitude
like after the fact that I take the next
day like just in general
um I don't know in all honesty I don't
know maybe I'm not really focused on
that I mean I woke up in a good mood
today I was tired but like I woke up in
a good mood I guess I don't I guess I
don't really think about that
right have you had any Dipsy Doodles
while you've been doing the mushrooms
elaborate
um like dips in emotion or
no it's just it's been pretty uh it's
been pretty you know the whole the whole
because I'm not really tripping or
seeing anything it's just like a really
most of it really what it has been is
just giving me energy
yeah so it just gives me energy for a
long period of time to be able to just
like stay up and hang out you're micro
dosing it
yeah but I feel like a gram and a half
to two grams but I'm also not taking the
mushrooms I'm taking like I did the
jody-s chocolate bar right because I
don't have any like actual mushrooms
neither do I anymore I think I left them
in uh yeah I don't know why I didn't
take those where where did I leave them
you left them in Harris Michigan the
hotel room
that's right I'll read some more this
week yeah I wanna I wanna I don't like
the taste of them but they hit harder
I think so so I like a gram and a half
of that compared to a gram and a half
chocolate bar is going to be a way
different experience what about the gram
and a half chocolate bar versus a gram
and a half capsule
um I would say pretty similar
um honestly the the gram and I have
capsule the first time I took it I had
like a little like a little bit of color
vibrations off of certain things
um
and it was a way more giggly High the
second time I did it I took the same
amount and I just felt really energetic
I took a a fifth pill to get me to like
one point like just under two grams but
I think by that time everything else had
already passed so it was yeah I was like
I'll just try to add it on top of it but
it was way too late all right well keep
me up to date man yeah it's been fun